[Music]
mother logo overload when he thinks this
trip through CGI space is going to get
me excited about interstellar travel
when in fact all my future astronaut
sperm just tragically died of
disinterest it's a salient seeing the
president with more speech because this
future alien technology knows it wasn't
recorded right sitting up in bed after a
nightmare cliche
okay let's unpack this super
expositional nightstand shot first he's
reading about the German air force also
he has a cane so he's clearly old and
hobbled now third of all we have the
repeating doodles of a circle and it's
radius fancy pen fancy watch dell remote
control and a phone with more buttons
than the Starship Enterprise
I guess we're supposed to glean that
this former president is still obsessed
and being haunted by visions of a circle
with a line in it but mostly I'm just
concerned about that dell remote it's
upside down here so you have to work to
see the logo which you think would make
Dell less likely to pay for this
placement and yet here it is baffling
man I didn't even know Dell made remote
control devices for 20 years the world
to see no armed conflict nations have
put their petty differences aside these
Jumbotron screens are hovering Will
Smith has better things to do in the
scene you're the one that's bagged in
the White House it's too bad Mae Whitman
died and wasn't able to reprise her role
as Oh still alive still actively working
in Hollywood - wow this is awkward
liam hemsworth is in the moon vehicle
which might explain the break he and
Miley took in real life though you could
just as easily blame that pink armpit
hair phase she went through around the
time of this movie's events I mean
filming I was the youngest valedictorian
in the history of the Academy expose
Austin in case you confused it with one
of Jupiter's moons rather there are only
36 women on this moon base well that
number is worthless unless or until you
tell me how many men there are but movie
doesn't care about that it just wants to
slide in and I've been away a long time
and I'm who me joke movie expects me to
believe that this one tiny ship is going
to prevent this big thing from falling
and commanded by an inferior Hemsworth
no less engines are overheating but the
movie despite personally giving us that
information will ignore the consequences
of it you're grounded until further
notice what he means to say is you're
grounded until the aliens attack again
and we need an outside the box thinker
like yourself get me director Levinson
you mean that guy who did diner you
think he'd make this better I'm all for
it he's an original sign despite
commanding alien technology over the
last 20 years cellular service is still
spotty you need to
me seriously I've been chasing you
across the planet for three weeks now
excuse me who who are you again did this
guy just start yelling at David right
now halfway to their destination without
David even knowing who he is or why he's
here I mean this movie how holy they
dragged him for maniac into this movie
didn't they
she looks more uncomfortable in this
then she doesn't Antichrist and that
movie involved a scene in which scissors
were used in a manner that violate their
Terms of Use oh look the same basic
circle with a line doodle the former
president has been drawing a lot I bet
that means something despite the doodles
simplicity he's people for a grin war
with the aliens for ten years
a premise let is way better than this
whole movie but sure let's shoot this
one instead
it happened on its own two days ago and
now we get the Winnie that kick starts
the movie the ship turned its own lights
on the call is coming from inside the
house of course your wrath is the only
ship that landed in 96 total bull of
course the first movie made it look like
every ship crash landed and was on fire
after they destroyed the mothership but
sure this one managed to land on its own
and no one said about it they were
drilling I don't know
case closed then I guess visa we don't
know so it must be impossible to crack
20 years ago and we destroyed the
mothership we detected a burst in an
x-band frequency directed toward deep
space funny how we're only just now
hearing about that del paid good money
to have their laptop slams shut in
frustration
and an upside-down remote control shot
on the night stamp you're a pilot he's a
pilot the other guy's a pilot I'm giving
out wings international legacy squadron
also this movie just got a lot more
stealth than I think it intended Captain
Hillier
considering he died during a test flight
how do you feel taking off for the moon
man this reporter is the worst and the
screenwriters decided that Will Smith's
character died during a test flight
instead of from dating a stripper China
has been integral to the earth space
defense program amazing how helpful
China suddenly became and all the movies
released in the last few years
Jasmine took the rear career path from
exotic dancer to respected doctor in the
last one years and also of course she's
a doctor because we're in an Emmerich
movie so they're sending an elite squad
of eight pilots to the moon and that's
supposed to what I'm a guy I like pretty
girls but even I'm not comfortable with
how sexualized this girl's deep laning
ritual is this is the very definition of
the male gaze for a sexy pilot to
suddenly overcome with the urge to
excrete pheromones while standing inside
a jet
um can't they just not be related why is
everybody somebody something in this
movie milk and all the last thing I said
that my parents was I hated them
ladies and gentlemen roland emmerich
pandering to the cheapest of human
emotions in the sleaziest of ways once
again please applaud jake decides to
watch the training video where he nearly
killed Dylan possibly realizing that an
unseen audience needs a backstory
brackish makes up for miss coma after
everything alien related in this movie
awoke from comas two days ago this just
came in from Hubble still using the
Hubble after mastering all that alien
technology huh didn't want to give the
James Webb telescope a shot out sure
it's not an operation yet but this is a
movie damn it up the alert level to red
to red alert then I'm calling Star Trek
on your ass listen I want you to pack up
your stuff and go to your sisters this
guy just got evidence there may be an
alien attack and he's the moon base
commander and his first move is to
selfishly call his own wife before
notifying any government types also how
does a moon base detect the Saturn
weirdness before Earth it's not that
much further out that it's measurably
closer to Saturn I feel like this whole
moon base is just a little too James
Bond II and stupid I know we're not on
good terms with aliens but that's racist
how did you suffer so much of their
language how did you determine he
deciphered anything from a one-second
glance at this wingdings board you must
be the pilot China sent that's your
opening line in addition to being lame
and obvious it's also kind of racist I
was wondering if you wanted to get a
drink maybe fall in love guys I think
the syn counter just died from that
pickup line we may need to manually
count sins with an abacus after this
take em out commander the sphere of
peace thing that just flew to our moon
to warn us about the aliens decided to
do so without trying to communicate with
us first or sending images of Hitler
just flew to our airspace and expected
the best all so sudden alien wormhole
ship thing sucks the dust off the moon
and everyone wants to shoot it except
Goldblum and in this instance I gotta
side with everyone but gold blue shoot
that bat of the sky now I don't care
that the movie will go on to show
Goldblum was probably right
use logic damn it they're coming back
and this time we won't be able to stop
this isn't Bill Pullman playing the
president from the last movie gone crazy
this is Bill Pullman the actor talking
about Emmerich and its production team I
will avenge it brother guessing your
brother died during the first movies
invasion but it's way more interesting
to think that stuff cheetah killed your
brother and that's why you killed and
stuffed it cuz any other explanation for
that stuff cheetah makes you a 100%
asshole I cannot root for FYI
well how do you think you're going
listen discount John Oliver he's clearly
going to space with that spaceship right
there and your question is unnecessary
or at least misguided why in georgia's
floyd everybody else is
awesome this character so fun what with
the constant whirring yelling in
exasperation
glad David decided to let him go on this
trip Independence Day to would like to
remind you how much David hates flying
and how much 2016 Jeff Goldblum hates
acting I'm actually glad no one is
buying this guy's book puts him in his
place you're the father of the guy not
the guy you should have written a book
about being the guy's father but no you
wrote this and now you suffer a former
president with full Secret Service
detail has escaped using the fake body
in the bed method because of course he
has that is that's the crash site thanks
David
all these people but where's the
humanity in this shot there's more
realism in The Adventures of Sharkboy
and Lavagirl 3d how did president want
more get past several levels of security
to even get this close to the current
president every alien invasion movie
these days makes it look like the moon
is always in some fixed positions that
aliens can visit just before they reach
Earth ships more than 3,000 miles in
Guyana that seems excessive I like a
space computer that repeats everything
it says it's helpful in case anyone
missed that first broadcast it's like
that yeah yeah science fiction
entertaining and useful movie replaces
original films landmark destruction
scenes with moon based destruction
scenes and I'm sorry just doesn't have
the impact if I'm honest I don't really
give a shit about the moment guy with
headphones can't hear or feel
destruction going on around him cliche
it's an Emmerich staple this guy is
really just shocked at how familiar all
this is Man of Steel how can this ship
with two main characters on it be so
close to the massive destruction without
being affected by it wait never mind I
think I answered my own question what
goes up must come down while I admit
Jeff Goldblum is good at saying cheesy
action lines like this what the fuck is
he talking about there's an alien ship
landing on earth that never went up but
merely came down on earth so what the
screenwriter
lazy much months before the brexit vote
London gets good and hard something
tells me this is only slightly more
impossible than John Cusack miraculous
drive in 2012 this scene could also be
accidentally cut into 2012 but I
wouldn't know the difference I'd like to
get the landmarks even when the movie is
being self-aware it somehow ends up
being wrong this is clearly incidental
damage from all the other three going on
but let's laugh it up about how the
aliens are landmark racist take your
path yeah yeah me too all five
screenwriters on this film collectively
high-fived over the pee pants joke
because it was righteous in its
originality and hilariousness better
come and see this you better come and
see this okay here's judd hirsch has
failed author character cooking a steak
on a boat named after a Madonna song
the Atlantic just in time to be in the
center of the action because we all
loved him so much in the first movie
this will surely make us forget Will
Smith rejected this turd rain you take
the lead
I gotta see about someone because that's
how the military works
Dylan flies back to the hospital just in
time to witness how much of a failure he
is it's saving his mom and she's dead so
the question is did Vivica Fox ask for
too much money did the screenwriters
only just get out of character
motivations 101 does roland emmerich
hate strippers turn doctors yeah Judd
Hirsch is basically Jesus in this boat
I'm no longer remotely worried about his
chances of survival he's untouchable
luckily for brackish he decided to
escape his room at just the moment when
President Widmore arrived to open up the
alien prison the other all the systems
the depressed deranged former president
overrode your modern-day security system
this movie is aggressively stupid well
now apparently the pronoun game spans
across the universe I feel like this is
some sort of metaphor where analog kills
digital this is independent state to so
probably not just shut up okay that's
enough
I feel like this movie almost certainly
already showed me these underage driving
melodramatic teens and yet this still
feels like the first time I'm seeing
them and I hate them I think they're
after our molten core
yeah but maybe they're trying to save
humanity and get the earth spinning
again like in the classic 2003 film the
core also I guess there are no other
good heat sources and the nearby solar
systems like Suns and totally after the
molten core you nailed it dude
interesting that he's looking at a
family photo in which the kid in the
picture is not him and it will Smith get
a 10 million dollar photograph
appearance fee for this movie couldn't
save her too late
I wasn't cheeky enough this red mass on
the top of the ship that's your target
it's exactly the same but it's not in
any way like the Death Star's weakness
we're gonna send a fleet of drones to go
in ahead of you and disable their
shields makes you think you have the
technology to disable their shields
fourth of July wait those fuckin aliens
waited 20 years and then attacked earth
on the same calendar days before
stupid-ass aliens Jesus she's happy
because she's one of those pilots before
they all took off and now that thing is
no longer after few so now this plasma
drill will take forever to cut down to
the Earth's core even though it clearly
has none of the earthly limitations I
did when I tried to shovel my way down
to it
come and we have visible only just now
how does any ship avoid being hit by
these things seriously there's so much
junk on this screen it's like playing
that old Genesis game target earth that
was impossible unless you put in a cheat
code and loaded the cartridge into a
toaster liam hemsworth and Will Smith's
son collaborate to take out a single
alien ship and are left alone by
everyone to do that despite there being
like ten times the alien ships in this
airspace as Earth ships whatever cool
movie moment watch it be damned everyone
you should be dead is what I'm saying I
think we need to fly inside to be even
more like Star Wars sir she knows coming
yeah cuz she looked at her front window
look if you're gonna give this guy a
connection to the aliens can you at
least make him spew something not super
obvious it's a trap a trap for what why
would you lead these pilots in here only
to disable their jets do they need a
live humans for some reason I don't
think they do
which makes this it's a trap scene
pretty pointless well there goes HBO
again she baited us yeah she attacked
you and you counter-attack but she was
ready for it she's a regular Bobby
Fischer aliens are attacking the space
and the doors are being forcefully
opened and yet no one has tried to take
madam president anywhere safe she's
basically closer to the doors than
anyone in the room even all members of
the presidential line of succession are
presumed dead and buried I swear you
want to sir well isn't that convenient
every member of the presidential line of
succession luckily this character is
being played by William Fichtner have a
little faith you want to talk about
faith watching Joey King bitch out judd
hirsch for using colloquialisms during
an alien invasion is not anywhere near
my list of things I want to see because
I am NOT rolling ever thank you God why
if the two right lanes are so backed up
people are outside their vehicles is
this left lane so wide open I live in
America dammit and I know for a fact
this third Lane would be backed up too
and there'd be ten makeshift lanes on
the fields on either side it would also
be backed up this planet has been
unified in a way that John precedent in
human history movie thinks it's going to
give Bill Pullman another rousing speech
moment but realizes Bill Pullman will
only ever be allowed to have one of
those in his lifetime dude is giving a
motivational speech to one guy but
others take notice and begin closing in
to hear the rest of a cliche
to me is our line look if you're gonna
bring alien vs. predator into this we've
lowered the bar to the point where we're
not even high jumping anymore we're
curling here's where the movie had a
great opportunity to be an awesome alien
sci-fi film having American pilots
fighting in the alien ecosystem that is
located entirely on this huge ship but
instead the movie totally glosses over
this is something they need to get away
from rather than bathing
how long can Earthlings hold their
breath underwater on an alien space god
dammit I am NOT even gonna finish that
sentence movie can Daryl lick my balls
also Independence Day Goblet of Fire
this dumbass touches an alien sphere
without anyone seeing it before it's too
late and it just so happens to be the
thing that opens this booking speeder I
mean damn it my species shed our
biological existence for a virtual one
thousands of years ago so your species
is a bunch of Lucy's then I came to
evacuate as many of you as possible but
instead of simply speaking English to
you right away and giving you this
awesome warning I needed to show up to
your moon base like an idiot and get
myself shot up first tracted it's molten
core they use them to refuel their ships
and grow their technology don't ask how
they do that with a core that is mostly
iron nickel alloy it's terrifying and
super cool the system holds the key to
superior technology that's why you lost
right I mean they beat you you said
you're the sole survivor why would I
believe your tech is superior and there
is a hidden planet where I teach
refugees from other fallen worlds how to
build weapons that will defeat them so
there's a hidden planet that somehow
magically appears to refugees as a flee
their planet and once they land on said
planet they're told to go find a sphere
she knows what to do next I mean there
are so many questions that will be
answered by this movie because it thinks
it's getting another sequel but now that
I am activated the Queen will detect my
signature and hunt me down maybe you
should have sent an instruction manual
first before coming here if we hide the
real sphere inside the isolation chamber
this spheres frequency can be read from
space how much can an isolation chamber
really do filled with cold fusion bombs
and lure her out to the soft flats kuna
ear movie you set off cold fusion bombs
you're gonna kill everyone from here to
Houston not if we use the shield
generators from this base to containment
laughs well I checked out an hour ago
but this sounds suspiciously like both
to me we were wrong we do not have seven
hours until the earth core breach
we only have one what a shocker the
professional estimators in a roland
emmerich movie were way off on their
predictions and the danger is a lot more
imminent I'll fly it in now you won't
president Whitmore got ready for this
just in time to crush his daughter's
dreams of being a hero Julius finds a
magic bus that the driver abandoned
right when the station wagon was about
to run out of gas
excuse me down here there you go
this movie saw guardians of the galaxy
loved star-lord but failed to learn
anything about story or originality in
the process so we end up with this bolt
while Jake does this can I ask again
what the point of this trap was they
basically allow the ships in and
everyone realized oh no it's a trap and
that sounded like something really
really bad to what end
they could have simply not trapped these
guys and shot them down outside easily
the aliens didn't need anything from
them so this trap is totally worthless
just technology hasn't changed at all
interface
sounds like that's a change in
technology then doesn't it also amazing
after the first movie that the aliens
didn't advocate locking technology for
their ships or require a password or
alien DNA or anything that will prevent
humans from using a man I just want you
to know you'll make it out of here this
is a cliche but I don't have the
strength to write out the whole thing
I'm just hoping you feel me on this one
this is radios okay first of all how
would you know that it's the world
shortwave radio message board still
operating during this super obvious
alien invasion second of all why would
you say this even if it's true are you
trying to tell the aliens how to find
your listeners or language I mean I'm
kind of assuming you won't speak English
here otherwise good luck
yesterday he collapsed come with me
quick this dad is a Kurt and if you
didn't realize Bill Pullman was gonna
die in this movie probably while
sacrificing himself to save the planet
then you don't watch movies very often
it's good to see you flying again okay
first of all saying this instead of I'm
sorry I lied to you five minutes ago it
places in the air like you would know
terrible father yet the movie felt the
need to recreate the sacrificial plane
flying into the alien ship scene from
the first movie
because roland emmerich only has like
two ideas max and those two ideas
keeping and producing inbred child ideas
that are somehow even worse well if she
said why fighters till
to us this gal would be excellent at
cinemasins but terrible at cliche
screenwriting there has to be a second
whammy duh yep
all-powerful alien Queens hold grudges
just like you and me somebody's asshole
dogs in danger cliche it feels like this
alien should have easily caught up to
the bus and destroyed it by now or were
these ships trying to blow up the alien
should have destroyed the bus by now we
are within six minutes actually nine but
you couldn't possibly know the movie
with the stor time to suit its needs but
good ticking clock narration dude can
come on movie how much bullshit you
expect me to swallow like all of it I do
have a gag reflex you know is there ever
going to be a realization from these
pilots that they're shooting is it
working Oh what did the shield lose its
maximum amount of hit points thank god
this video game has been boring and
confusing by the way why is the alien
queen so intent to destroy the school
bus and Patricia isn't the mission for
her to find the sphere why does she care
so much about these assholes this alien
queen is so motivated by flashes of
anger it's a wonder she ever got this
far and our earth takeover attempt how
much you wanted that Liam Hemsworth
saved her ass like all the dollars I got
- very well he just ruined my back she
lets a second guitar of our system this
is where movies officially make you
angry these assholes flew out of the
mothership 15 minutes ago but did the
alien queen want to take control then
nope just allow them to fly out no
problem what about when these ships were
firing at her a minute ago nope
just allow them the time to save not Mae
Whitman then control it these guys have
no manual controls and the alien ships
they stole then they turn on the fusion
thrusters manually mind you and
amazeballs
I gotta controls back make up controls
back Big Town if this movie just steal
from Independence Day and aliens while
taking Close Encounters of the Third
Kind name in vain
nice gag but his hands are both on the
wheel and these wipers just turned on so
that's some magic bull or else he's got
a child under the dashboard where we
can't see that's just turned on the
wipers which raises even more questions
and none of these crashing alien ships
landed on anything or anyone important
the end the marriage you trying to shoot
me this joke is unfunny what's worse is
that it's actually kind of offensive
casually suggesting violence is
commonplace in marriages but mostly it's
unfunny yes let's let all the little
school children get super up close to
the we think she's dead but we don't
know for sure alien queen and her
dripping bodily fluids Jesus
10 years after this here in Brockovich
takes David and his dad for all they're
worth in a vicious yet just class-action
lawsuit on behalf of these kids who all
developed Neptune pneumonia
you guys should stay with me for a while
but we'd really like that what the pink
movie this is some kind of prequel to
lovely bones or something I mean old man
walks up to four young kids and just
adopts them on the spot with no checks
and balances why is the ship flying away
they killed the Queen sure but what now
possesses it to go back into space is
that something the sphere told us I'm
not sure I get it wants us to lead their
resistance well you should have made a
better movie then because that's not
happening unless Fox wants to hemorrhage
more money we're still getting one
anyway oh I feel like you're driving me
to a court-martial this is crazy
hey I'm in Hawaii - I may throw up on
you B as in Furby as in Belize beautiful
place just stay calm and don't burn this
is no time to panic this is the perfect
time to panic
Charlie look at those fields down there
are fields endless fields filled with
cold fusion bombs and lure her out to
the southwest and put any stock in this
cold fusion Mambo Cambodia